it's april 23rd 1997 I'm on my third day
of boot camp in South Carolina I just
joined the US Army I'm around people I
have no clue about I know nobody I just
got into my third fight in three days in
the laundry room and it was one of those
fights where both of us are blood you
know we are blood it's terrible it's a
very bad fight it was his first fight
was my third fight my drill sergeants
pulled me in and there's five of them
sitting there I'm on this side and they
said son we just want to tell you
something military's not for you you
need to go back home so what are you
telling me he says you don't need to be
in a military do you even want to be
here you do not want to be here I'm 17
18 years old and I'm quite I'm not
saying anything they said look here's
what we're going to do to you typically
when this happens this is your third
fight in three days we absolutely do a
dishonorable discharge and we send you
home here's what we want you to do you
have tonight to think about your
decision okay we think you're not made
for the military we want you to go and
make as many calls as you want tomorrow
morning at 5:00 a.m. you need to tell us
if you're staying in where you're going
home our suggestion to you is you need
to go home son that's what you need to
do this is not for everybody and it's
definitely not for you so I go to my
room and I start making all the calls
they give me a room with a phone I start
calling all my buddies every one of my
friends girlfriends everybody the same
pad come home pad come home Pat come
home every single person says Pat come
home
I was fun I was the guy you wanted to go
out put I was that guy
and I go to my bunk and had a friend of
mine Wiggins never forget Wiggins he was
from Texas at that time and I had three
songs I was listening to on repeat okay
back then it was Walkman so I'm
listening to my Walkman and for the
entire night asleep that night I
listened to three songs and all I
thought about a kid thinking about this
decision one song was uh sure
you make me one I had just come out the
other song was by Blackstreet look how
remember these albums and these songs
I'm listened to it was black Street the
song was don't leave me grown
don't leave me girl please stay with me
to night and the third song was by Brian
McKnight I think it was I don't know the
name of the song it's until I feel your
heartbeat pounding next to mine I've got
a war to do till every single star up in
the sky knows that I belong to you those
three songs all night it's all I listen
to and I was very emotional it was a
defining moment of my life I wanted to
go back and party I'm at the prime time
of my life and partying 17 18 I didn't
tell my dad and tell my family I woke up
in the morning I went to the sergeant's
and I said I'm staying in I'm gonna make
this work and let me tell you what
happened a part of it was now that they
know I'm in all they thought about was
find ways to break me make sure I got
out of the army they made me do more
push-ups one day I was doing so push-ups
it was like our fourth day I couldn't
salute like I literally had to go like
this to salute I couldn't suit my
shoulders were gone they were wiped out
my legs I'd lost 24 pounds in two weeks
because we kept running and running but
David four more miles but David four
more miles and I can't stand running why
am I telling you these stories everybody
wants to be a deca millionaire everybody
says Pat how's it feel nav and all these
millions of dollars and everybody around
the world knows you and thought that all
this stuff that they say yeah that's
great
you take the military out I'm not who I
am today for everybody it's different
I'm here with 144 other entrepreneurs
I'm in Harvard obviously writing at
Harvard Business School OPM program and
everyone I talk to they typically have a
one year two year of extreme hardship in
their lives that they had to go through
for me was the military I lived in Iran
lots of hardship I went through war
so horribly the refugee camp lots of
hardship parents divorce streets all
that lots of hardship military lots of
hardship and then it built me to the men
that I am I was a 21 and from there the
rest was figuring out my way and what I
wanted my life so I learned 19 things
from the military that helped me become
a millionaire now I want to tell you
about it today and we can replace
millionaire with deca millionaire with
entrepreneur with C or whatever you want
to call it
the title for the sake of the title we
use the title millionaire because
somebody asked me Pat I want to be a
million I'm thinking about joining the
military dadada I think the kids named
Ari what was the kid's name
Dre what Dre from the bay Dre I'm going
to give you some love because this whole
message was prompted by you Dre said hey
Pat I'm currently in high school I'm
planning on taking a year off after I
graduate serve in the military learn
discipline and work ethic for my future
career can you please make a video on
your experience in the military maybe
you know some advice on points that
follow so let me get right into I
learned 19 things 19 things that
military with and I'm going to get right
into it and I'll go to fairly quickly
number one managing chaos military was
all about managing chaos everything's
happening at the same time you have to
find a way to be poised and we saw
people that couldn't handle it I
remember one of the exercises that we
had right before you become a graduate
is you have to low crawl under these
wires while above you
semi-automatic the semiautomatic weapons
are shooting right above you and that's
all you're here it's late night it's
raining it's heat it's humid it's
terrible and you're low crawling with
this noise that's chaos you're panicking
you've never been through that before
what do I do
there was a kid on the base that same
day there was a kid on the base that had
to do this he can handle he stood up
boom done deal okay
that's kind of like in business you have
all these you feel like there's so many
chaos in business you don't know how to
handle it all of us and you make one
mistake in business one stupid mistake
you lose you into our business because
you don't know how to manage chaos so
one thing I learned from the military
number two is mission driven military's
all about mission we have a mission and
here's what we have to accomplish let's
go at the mission entrepreneurship if
you can figure out a way to make your
business or the money part you want to
be a millionaire you want to be a
successful CEO an entrepreneur mission
driven what is your mission you got
we'll complete this mission you cannot
leave a mission as our whatever we'll
try we'll run no mission driven let's
complete this mission what is the
mission let's go complete this mission
that's exactly how to military that's
exactly how tis with business as well
number three learning how to get a lot
done with limited resources you know a
lot of times people will say what Pat I
wish I had money I don't know a lot of
entrepreneurs that started off with ten
million bucks on somebody given the
money unless if it was their parents I
wasn't one of them I'm not coming from a
family that's very wealthy my mother had
to go back to you run because she ran
out of money and my dad was a cashier at
a 99-cent store you know both of them
were good people my dad was the hardest
working person I know but we didn't have
any money so I started off my business
by making sales $100 Commission $200
Commission $500 Commission thousand auto
command I saved right and then I was
able to open up my own office then I was
able to hire a staff assistant all this
other stuff but in the military you got
to learn how to make things work
unlimited resources like think about it
we go to the field and you go into
whatever is going on there's a mission
there's a war there's something going on
and you're living in the Humvee or you
have the uh you know you have a little
bit amount of water and you have a
little bit amount of food in here a
couple or you know food that you're
eating and how long is this going to
last them we got to make sure our
rations are going to be lower in this
you got in the same thing goes with
business sometimes you got to work with
limited amount of resources that you
have
number four is learning how to multitask
and a lot of times there's a lot of
people that talk about multitasking is
not a possible thing to do the power of
habit which is a great book so one of my
favorite books of all time that I've
read for business but I'm here to tell
you I hate to say it there's
multitasking in the military you can't
just say this all I'm doing is standing
here on guard and I'm just watching over
there
really while you're doing this you're
speaking to somebody and you're waving
people while you're looking over there
and you're going like this or like that
and you have to go lower and you have to
position yourself and you have to drink
some water to stay hydrated that's
multitasking business is the same thing
you may be doing something here while
you got to do this over here while
you're handling this so how do you do
that well I don't know how to multitask
I'm sorry in the world of business
there's going to be many instances
that you have to somewhat learn to
multitask especially during the survival
phase until you can get a ton of support
and match up the areas you're not good
with with support team hire staff hire
support team hire team and then you're
able to do what you're very good at but
during the survival phase you're going
to be multitasking quite a lot as you're
building your business I learned at a
military number five learning how to
perform under pressure I think sometimes
people are afraid to perform under
pressure and more important let me say
this to you you'll learn a lot from
anybody on how they perform under
pressure now keep this in mind let me
say this and stay with me I'm gonna say
it slowly
nobody performs better under pressure
than they do when there is no pressure
let me explain Robert Horry was known as
a great three-point shooter he wants
seven championships right great when do
you think he shoots better threes in
practice without anybody looking at him
and there's nobody guarding him or in
the game with three seconds left on the
shot clock
of course practice however here's the
difference there are people that perform
better under pressure than other people
perform under pressure
they're both under pressure one
outperforms the other one I can tell you
the world of business you got to learn
how to perform under pressure better
when you're on war when you're military
when you're soldier you'll learn how to
perform under pressure the same thing
goes with sports some of you have played
sports organized sports and you know how
it is when it's last minute and your
coach is telling you got to do this
we're counting on you and all this that
some people can't handle being counted
on we're counting on you this is it you
got to make this last place oh my god
everybody's can what if I don't do it I
might be a loser one see that's when you
learn about somebody when they have to
perform under pressure and that's when
the leader is born during moments like
that I'm a byproduct of that 17 18 year
old kid I would I would give anything to
have a camera watching myself at that 17
18 year old guy when the five drill
sergeants gave me the option to come
back home and party and said you are not
worth staying in the military I'd love
to see that this 37 year old version PVD
is built because that's 17 18 versus PVD
made a decision
during pressure time just like you're
going to need to make some decisions
during pressure
and while most people give up during
those pressure type situations you're
not you're going to stick through and
it's going to be difficult but you're
going to stick to if you do obviously
that's where the payoff comes number six
military talking about how to manage
risk everything is about managing risk
what is managing risk we flank left we
have a risk here because the enemy is on
the other side and we have to figure out
what they're going to be don't we we go
this way we're looking at mountains
we're going to need to climb so we may
get over the mountains but we're going
to be tired so which risk is more
important if we go straight we don't
really know what's going on if it's
straight so if enemies on both sides
we're going to be in right in the middle
and that's ambush time we're done no
matter how we flank and however we go
through it we're done deal so what we do
we want to stay here the risk if we stay
here is they attack us what if we
retreat if we retreat them they're going
to be known that we're afraid you have
four choices five choices left straight
right stay retreat do I send somebody
there is risk the same thing with
business do I go here do I go here do
what do I do here you're managing risk
as a business owner and to create wealth
it's all about managing risk now keep in
mind I want you to understand this part
everything I'm telling you you're seeing
the final product so you're saying oh my
god Patrick speaks and I feel like
internet this is the final product of me
having to go through those types of
situations just like you're going to
need to go through those types of
situations point number seven let me go
through the point number seven
thick-skinned and I'll tell you what
part of military taught me thick-skinned
oh my gosh the military sarcastic I mean
everybody was in a motor pool which
means I was a Hummer mechanic if you're
in a motor pool some of the most
sarcastic people in the military work in
a motor pool where under the Humvee and
where I was working on 16 Hummers that
were assigned to me and then I had 5lm
TVs and FM TVs and I was a Hemet driver
these massive hammered drivers that we
would go which was fascinating that's
what I worked on those were assigned to
me so mechanics are out there just
saying the most random things to each
other when I was in boot camp can you
imagine your drill sergeants saying the
following thing to you hey boy hey boy
you got to go home
you got to grow at home I do you know
who she's with right now who your best
friend your best friend right now she's
moaning right now his name your
girlfriend and you have access to no
phone for two months figure that one out
like you're mentally off for two months
that's what they're telling you and
they're writing you letters and your
letters you get a chance to write on
sandy's to send them on can you handle
that that's the fake skin part so let's
take that and let's talk about business
oh my gosh somebody said I'm not
interested in your product someone quits
are you kidding me that's thick skin
sensitivity this person screamed at me
this person hung up on me
this person closed the door on me this
person said this behind my back
this person bought the product then they
cancelled and then they told everybody
I'm terrible
thick skin thick skin Unni thick skin
military teaches a lot of thick skin and
you need thick skin to be a millionaire
number eight tribe we learn how to have
a tribe everything for me was about
camaraderie my boy Brantford McElroy
Felix there's a long list of these names
chip Clingerman these were brothers of
mine I mean I'm talking brothers of mine
is what they were and we had amazing
camaraderie we had amazing camaraderie
together amazing I'm talking we had a
tribe that we'd go out and everybody
back everybody up let me explain to what
I mean by this it is an element of gang
type of a thing in the military you
become a gang I was part of the three to
six engineers at the hundred first
Airborne Division Air Assault it was
part of hhc and our crew me and Bradford
my buddy if anybody said like Bradford
one day Bradford ina come come back at
the chow hall and we're sitting there
and we were so competitive who could do
more push-ups I would go beat him in
push-ups who could run better he was a
much better runner than one who can do
more sit-ups who was a better recipe was
a phenomenal wrestlers what Bradford was
loved our relation we were briefed you
if we if we bled we were you would think
we're related to each other right one
day we got into it and I said Brad
furred let's go to what he called the
rack
to ballcourt we went to each step East
that was a gym and we went in there and
then I said you ready yeah ready two
girls were playing racquetball so you
guys mind if we use the racket but for
about 10-15 minutes oh sure I said
Radford you're upset I mean yeah I'm
upset at you let's take it out on each
other and see what we can do I'd know
prom ready go bomb
we started started with pushing then
wrestling then swinging then punching
then bleeding then hugging then leaving
then some other people made fun of us
and then fighting them that's the tribe
now I'm not telling you to go start
fights with everybody I'm not endorsing
and I'm 18 years old at that time
and there's a very high level of
knucklehead meanness in that can I'm not
endorsing any of that right now to you
the point I'm trying to make to use we
don't how to create a tribe in the world
of business when you build a business
this is my suggestion there's many ways
you could do it for me I love a team
that is committed to one another that's
willing to work their tails off to make
sure the mission becomes a reality and
if there's a tribe component to it it is
more important for everybody to be able
to count on one another you're on that
in the military I learned that in
military again a part of that you
learned in sports as well next is
leadership you learn how to lead very
very quickly you have no choice but to
lead because everything in the military
is leadership so you're either going to
lead follow or get out of the way you've
heard that many times but there was a
development process to it so the whole
get out of the way part it's the same
you say get out of the way but at the
same time you're developing the people I
was being developed I was developing
other people people were being developed
we were all being developed in the
military there was a leadership
development component in military that
was constantly taking place leadership
next is learning other cultures let me
add something on a leadership site a lot
of times people have somebody in the
company that they saw you know I just
don't like this person boom boom they're
gone but there's no leadership
development now keep in mind there are
certain people that phone don't fit the
culture if somebody doesn't fit the
culture it's a wrong hiring process or
the person that was getting the job
light during the hiring process and they
were biessing you a lot and many people
will do that let's take that part out
let's say that doesn't exist everything
was right and you hired properly and
they said everything properly great and
they have a few things that they need to
do
fit the culture very well it's on you to
lead them and develop them you can't
just give up on people and say screw it
you know what you're fired next that's
leadership development that's the same
exact weight is on military we don't
give up on our peers we develop them
right
next learn in other cultures learning
other cultures I had to learn how to
deal with folks from Mississippi who
were Caucasian I had to learn how to
deal with Mississippi folks who were
african-american how to do with folks
who were from North Dakota certain
faiths I've never heard before I had to
learn how to deal with people from Utah
I had to learn how to deal with people
from New York who were Puerto Rican had
to learn how to do with different gangs
and the military attracts a lot of
former gang members I have to learn how
to deal with you know people that looked
at me and they say wait a minute now
keep him on my look and I'm shaved in a
Middle Eastern worry where are you from
you from Iran you know misconceptions
that to learn how to deal with
misconceptions you're from Iran
you're middle-eastern so what why are
you in the US Army misconceptions had to
learn how to deal with those ethnicities
and nationalities in the world of
business you know my company looks like
the United Nations we have every single
nationality out of our 2,400 agents you
name a nationality we pretty much have
we have all the different faiths we have
all the different bit you know
backgrounds what are we going to do say
no we only work with this types no I
want to be able to work with everybody
military taught that part to me in a
tremendous way next adapting the next
point is adapting you're learning how to
adapt to the situation that you have and
adapting sometimes you have a long time
to adapt sometimes you don't have a long
time to death you got to learn how to do
both in a world of business you want to
become a millionaire market changes what
do you need to do oh my gosh did you see
what happened - the market tanked adapt
oh my gosh we have a new president this
is so scary what are we going to do this
man is the worst man of all time this
woman is always one what a gaped oh my
goodness did you see what just happened
to the stock market adapt just adapt oh
my god my best client that adapt you
won't believe what just happened we're
moving adapt you got to learn how to
adapt you learn how to dad
military teaches you how to adapt and
the world of business you gotta learn
how to adapt without complaining
next survivability you gotta learn how
to survive with what you have the world
of business you need to learn how to
survive next
independence I learned how to be
independent I think one of my biggest
challenge when I talk to young men
especially in America when I speak to
young men is how dependent they are
under mom and their dad how dependent
they are dependent on somebody else to
do everything for them clothes you know
wash clothes every single thing they're
depending on somebody else to do
everything for them it is not a good
thing it is not a good thing I'm a big
fan of 16 17 18 year olds joining the
military for a year two years if they're
undecided what they want to do with
their lives it'll teach you so much
discipline and even I joined the US Army
I suggest Air Force because it provides
better education as well and the
opportunity for coming out you do a lot
more things but you can do Navy Marines
whatever may be right independence today
it's very difficult cutting the
umbilical cord with mom and kids and all
that stuff is so difficult for some
people military teaches you independence
Nexus strategy everything is about
strategy you got to learn what your
going to be doing with strategy world of
business you need to be strategic the
next point I learned is health
you got exercise why what are you going
to do when you go 36 hours on a shift
what are you going to do and you're
tired boom you're dead your unit is dead
then what so you're to sear your the
entrepreneur you need to be ready to
take your business to the next level you
may be working harder than ever the next
year two years three years you're tired
what happens you're dead your business
closes down why because you got tired
why don't you get tired because you gain
some weight why did you gain weight
because you eat fast food why do you
advance food because your excuses I'm an
entrepreneur I don't have any time to
prepare my food so you go eat fast food
and you put on weight I don't have time
to exercise that's your excuse I don't
have time to a proper diet that's your
excuse instead you don't need to eat
bread you don't need to need sweets you
don't need to add ice cream while you
eat those things that wounds your energy
you can take the steps and walk up and
stead of taking an escalator you don't
have to take the elevator you can
exercise and get a Fitbit you can track
your exercise routine this is health
militaries help businesses health next
is preparation lots of preparation
military lots of prepare preparation in
the world of business then you have
paranoia
you learn about paranoia what's going to
happen if we do this you need a little
bit of
healthy amount of paranoia again you've
heard me talk about this book and at
least five of my videos Andy Grove wrote
a book only the paranoid survive in a
military paranoia is very very critical
very very critical in the world of
business paranoid is also very critical
I was just talking to an entrepreneur
right now who runs a business doing
twenty million dollars per year and it's
doing very very well and I pull them
aside I said you seem a little too
excited I just want to give you some
counsel you're fed feedback when you're
dis excited this is when you got to be
more paranoid and he looks at me says
what do you mean that's it said don't be
too fired up and too excited be more
paranoid think tomorrow everything's
going to be taken away from you be more
paranoid says yeah yeah that's a good
point that's a good point be paranoid
you need them business as well and a
work ethic is the next point and the
last one to me is discipline if you
don't have work ethic if you don't have
discipline kiss the world of business
goodbye literally just don't go work in
as an entrepreneur if you want to be a
millionaire you're not discipline and
you don't have work ethic it's just not
going to happen and if you do get lucky
and make the millions guess what you're
going to lose it all you're going to
lose it all you don't want to work and
make the money and then you lose it all
you gotta have a strong work ethic and
you got to be disciplined so with that
being said dre was his name Drake from
the bank Dre from the bay Trey good
request I'm glad we did this
episode and now you know I'm a big R&B
guy I think I did a video talking about
R&B but now you know what R&B I listen
to back in the days and by the way I'm
not a fighter I'm a lover this is back
in the days when I used to do a lot of
foolish things when I was 17 18 years
old I can't think of the last time I got
into a fight now my fight is to help
inspire as many people around the world
as possible to become entrepreneurs my
fight is a whole different fight I got
going on right now that is still a fight
it just doesn't require these anymore
these have been retired for a long time
so here's what I need you to do
questions thoughts comment on the bottom
if you haven't subscribed to the channel
you know what you got to do subscribe to
the channel if you haven't shared any of
our videos please share this video tag
somebody and whatever post you're
watching with anyone you know who's a
veteran
sometimes veterans don't think they can
become entrepreneurs and they have a lot
of the qualities to become entrepreneurs
I want to be able to get a lot of
veterans military folks soldiers who
don't know what to do next they need to
watch this video to know they have
already possessed a lot of the
capabilities of being able to become an
entrepreneur they just need to learn how
to too so share this video with
them
and then what else we got I think we're
at ninety two thousand subs we are this
close to a hundred thousand subs to
celebrate this thing together thanks to
all of you awesome fans awesome value
tanners who do what you do and I get a
lot of private messages recently with
you guys telling me Pat I've got nine
more subscribers for you today I've got
10 more subscribers for the channel
today I got eight more subscribers and
we're getting a lot of videos of people
becoming great students of this channel
I'm getting emails of how much
note-taking is taking place how specific
people are learning and study and
there's a lot of people that watch this
content but I suggest you study this
content it's a big difference watching
is one time motivation you forget
studying is taking notes and processing
issues and then going back and looking
at it again I love how great of students
people are becoming with the content
that we have here and with that being
said stay tuned with more exciting
messages that we have coming up from
Harvard to you I can't wait to introduce
to you to a daily experience I've been
having here in Harvard which is going to
be fascinating that'll be launched very
soon take everybody bye-bye
you